[Music]
hello it's time for me to share one of
my most
deepest darkest saddest
stories that i ever held inside and not
told
anyone in over 15 years
that's right i broke my ass
it's not something i'm proud of and i'm
only making this video
to make sure that this happens to no one
else
i was young i was foolish and this could
happen to anyone do you know where your
ass is right now
you have to be aware at all times
otherwise
you run the risk of experiencing
the same pain i did long long long ago
i'm making this video because i made a
promise in a video a couple years ago i
said
i admitted that i broke my ass i'll tell
people in the future about this story
and i finally gathered enough courage i
finally gathered enough strength
to tell my story about how i broke my
ass
[Music]
i'm really appreciative people
gave me their respect and support for
doing this
it's not easy to talk about
but i will do my best to stay strong
throughout this video
[Music]
when i was 15 in sweden i was an awkward
swedish
weird underdeveloped little child
that's right everyone i used to be the
short kid you think i'm insecure about
my height for no reason
this has nothing to do with the story
i'm just giving context i didn't like
interacting with people i would prefer
to just sit home and play video games
i know the perfect cliche of a nerdy kid
nevertheless during summer we didn't
have a computer
at our summer place i had completely
different friend group there
there was basically internet was
non-existent so
i had no other choice but to hang out
and socialize with people
so even though i was a weird awkward kid
two months a year i
became a normal swedish boy i became a
summer child
and actually went out partying and did
all the stuff you do
so one week during the summer there's a
it's called sailing week i think
where everyone or a lot of people rent a
boat
they go sailing and they go from harbor
to harbor
and they get drunk and party so
me and my friends rented a sailing boat
altogether
well i think i think i was 50. i don't
know exactly how old i was
but me and my uh two closest friends we
rented a boat to
do basically just this i don't know why
my parents thought this was a good idea
i definitely would not let my kids do
this especially
mine with what we did i'm not gonna go
into details but i know what you're
thinking wow felix you have so many
amazing talents
you must be really good at sailing oh
yeah i was actually a sailing instructor
at one point
not really i mean i was a sailing
instructor but i was goddamn awful at
sailing
i really just got the job thanks for my
mom thanks mom i remember uh
during the so it was basically me and a
bunch of really young kids
and then during the beginning of the
course we asked like who wants to stay
up with felix and all the kids when yeah
me me me and i'm like yay i'm finally
popular with kids
kids like me this is great and then at
the end of the course
they ask the same question who wants to
stay with felix today
no one complete silence no one wanted to
say it with me all the kids hated me
because i wasn't good at sailing and we
kept capsizing and i kept lashing out on
all the kids because they sucked at
sailing and how is that my fault i'm
just the instructor
i also won one sailing uh
competition once which wasn't really a
sailing competition but it's one of
those things that i carried with me
throughout these 15 years and go
yeah i'm good at sailing i'm not good at
sailing and i'm willing to admit that
nevertheless we went sailing me and a
couple friends and it was a great time
we we partied and that was it
the problem is i get really really
really motion sick or seasick and anyone
that gets seasick you know how awful it
is it
stays with you until you get out of the
boat
it doesn't leave you for all this time
and it seems impossible to get rid of
you just want to die and it's not a good
feeling i didn't like the feeling
so i thought okay i'm gonna come
prepared
so i bought this motion sickness tablet
which is supposed to help with it
but they came with two side effects that
i was not intending for
number one it made me extremely sleepy
for some reason we had these weird
regulations in sweden where
with drugs i guess we don't really have
sleeping pills like in america
a lot of times what doctors do is that
instead of giving you sleeping pills
they say hey just take these motion
sickness tablets they do the same thing
and i didn't know about this so i
remember one time one of the days
during the sailing week it was so stormy
outside i remember looking outside be
like oh my god i'm gonna die from
seasickness if i go out on this
so i just downed a bunch of these motion
sickness tablets
being like it's not gonna happen to me
yeah i basically just drugged myself as
hard as i could
completely passed out i don't know how
long i was out but i remember
i was waking up way later in the evening
being super confused i didn't know where
i was
i looked outside i thought we arrived in
the new harbor realizing
we didn't even leave the shore everyone
was too afraid to sail that day
so i basically just drugged myself for
no reason but felix we want to hear how
you broke your ass well i'm getting
there
okay papa needs some watch time there's
another symptom
that i haven't mentioned yet and that
symptom is balance
that's right motion sickness is
connected to your ear
which is connected to your balance so i
would say or at least i like to think
that that's why my balance wasn't the
pristine
top condition that it's usually in i can
stand on one leg probably longer than
any other
person alive i pride myself in having
extremely well balanced
in everything thanos catchphrase
perfectly balanced as all things should
be
was actually invented by me i have
amazing balance
but taking these pills it knocked over
my balance
then we were also on this boat drinking
obviously as we were sailing
and that knocked down a few points on my
balance
scale as well and i think you know where
i'm going
with this sometimes when you sit down in
a sailing boat
it's a little bit awkward to sit down in
a sailing boat they're kind of weirdly
shaped so
it's not always the perfect place to
place your butt there's also a lot of
big objects
a lot of hard objects
that you could possibly fall on i was
gonna sit down
everything was fine it was a beautiful
sunny day we were all drinking
beer alcohol-free of course i was gonna
sit down
and i remember it so vividly i can
replay the whole scenario
in slow motion i was gonna sit down and
i was gonna grab my friend
while sitting down because like i said
it's awkward sitting down in a sailing
boat so i was gonna get help from my
friend to sit down
but this son of a gun moved away
in last second and i remember
so clearly just
falling out of my grass my hands knowing
oh god whatever my ass is gonna land on
it's not gonna be beautiful and let me
tell you it wasn't beautiful
i landed on a bench i don't know what
that's called in english
it's basically what you rail in the
sails with and it's pretty much as
uncomfortable
as you can imagine oh it's called winch
in english okay i screamed out
in terror in pain in shock
my ass ah my ass i was completely
immobilized
i couldn't move but most importantly i
was in deep
deep pain it really hurts to break your
ass i wasn't sure exactly what had
happened
but i knew something was wrong so me and
my friend as soon as we entered
we came to shore we came to harbor we
had to go to the hospital
we did the scan to confirm that yes
indeed
there was a crack in my ass
i didn't no longer just had one crack in
my ass i had two cracks in my ass and
that was
one crack too many to have let me tell
you i remember feeling very shocked
about this it was
a very traumatizing experience and
realization and i wasn't sure what they
were gonna do with me
how do you treat a cracked ass i thought
maybe
they would give me some sort of a
bandage kind of like a diaper or
something like that
and i remember asking the nurse what are
you gonna do and she's like well we
can't vanish your ass can we and i
thought yeah i guess you can
you live and you learn so instead they
just gave me a bunch of painkillers
and sent me off even though i had broken
eggs you know usually when you
break something i never actually broke
in anything in my body
so i was actually kind of looking
forward to it because everyone
you know when they're a kid they break
an arm they break a leg or whatever and
everyone's like oh it's so sad for you
and they get all this attention
they get people riding on your bandage
and no one's gonna ride on my
bandage ass bandage i realize all i have
to deal with
is the pain and suffering and most of
all the humiliation
you break an arm it's cool you break an
ass
it's not cool no one thinks that's cool
no one is proud to say
hey i broke my ass okay do you think i
want to be here
you think i want to tell this story
think again now the worst part of all
is that jonas jonas if you're watching
this video you sneaky son of a snake
jonas the guy that moved away when i was
trying to sit down while i was at the
hospital with my other friend
aegis good friend at least that doesn't
tell people
jonas told everyone he told everyone
that i had broken my ass and everyone
laughed
ha ha that's so funny i couldn't sit
straight
for god knows how long i was in pain
i was humiliated i was hurt
don't break your ass take it from me
take good care of it
[Music]
because you never know what's going to
happen to it
that's my story thanks for listening
don't break your ass
what you never played two for simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
you